but there's that Bruce Willis rest in
the moving bring on those finger guns
because we don't want to be demonetised
[Music]
fish I need an extra layer I look weird
there we go it look like douchey me
became Eddie Brock or something right
it's gonna get really hot under these
lights hos power through this review so
Death Wish is a remake of a movie
starring Charles Bronson and death wish
Bruce Willis is a surgeon three guys
enter his house with the intent to rob
it his wife gets shot and killed his
daughters in a coma and Bruce Willis
goes for some vigilante justice also
this is directed by Eli Roth so Eli Roth
brings his Eli Roth isms to death wish
that's not like a hurdle for death wish
to overcome the biggest hurdle in death
wish is the fact that I've just seen
this premise a zillion times before guys
family gets shot killed or assaulted guy
goes on vigilante justice spree how
often have you seen that premise I've
said I don't know if it's a metric [ __ ]
Tilian a few though doesn't help that
death wish is a remake of the movie
Death Wish which is the vigilante movie
most vigilante movies with that premise
that came after death wish hearkened
back to so it has come full circle there
is the argument to be had maybe I'm
making a straw man's arguments one of
those things I see and I'm like I'm
gonna hear this argument that it's the
wrong time for this movie maybe we
shouldn't have a movie that really kind
of promotes gun violence I imagine the
conversation of whether or not they
should have postponed this movie given
recent gun violence events probably
crossed someone's table they opted not
to whether or not they should have
delayed this movie I leave that debate
to the philosophers of the Twitterverse
I'm sure to talk about whether or not
the movie is good or worth your time or
money as the movie goes it's just kind
of mediocre when Bruce Willis starts
gunning people down it is hyper violent
and also entertaining cuz that's kind of
Eli Roth's thing spray a lot of blood
puncture a lot of arteries splatter the
walls with grey matter and you do have
that reaction when it happens like oh
[ __ ] what do we do with the rest of the
time all I gotta fill it with Bruce
Willis story and it's pretty weak I just
didn't give a [ __ ] when this movie was
begging me to give a [ __ ] Eli Roth does
door torture porn that's his thing his
forte so to speak it's not the emotional
weight of loss so when this movie tries
to portray that it just comes across as
awkward Bruce Willis is broken up
because his wife is dead Bruce Willis
then goes to visit his daughter whose
friend is there reading a book to her
the way Bruce Willis is interacting with
this girl he seems pretty spry he's kind
of giggling laughing making a couple of
jokes I just didn't get the feeling this
guy's
suffered an extreme loss very recently
and then the very next scene he's at the
therapy he's talking about how he can't
sleep he looks broken up again like that
scene was awkwardly filmed to be plugged
in somewhere and they plugged it in the
wrong spot you can make the leap well
maybe he's just hiding it deep down but
you can also make the leap that maybe
it's bad filmmaker I'm gonna go with
that leap because that's less of a leap
than the first link does the movie
doesn't really address the concept that
he's repressing emotions or putting on a
happy face and the awkward conversation
or this guy's like poachers on my land
let's get him they're shooting at these
guys there were poachers on his lands
where Bruce Willis like you know what
maybe I do need to take things into my
own hands again it's a moment where
Bruce Willis's character gets this
profound notion that's gonna change the
course of his life that has the audience
you're watching it like that could has
just been done better because in the end
this movie had moments of enjoyment in
it but in a world where we have the
premise of the character becomes a
vigilante because his family was
assaulted or killed on that nauseum the
movie doesn't really stand out it's not
better than a death sentence with Kevin
Bacon it's not better than the Thomas
Jane Punisher so as much as I want to
say you can knock a couple back and
enjoy the movie you can knock a couple
back and enjoy other movies and I'm not
gonna remember death wish and t-minus
one day yeah I've already forgot alright
so death wish have you seen it what did
you think about it or have you seen the
original death wish have you seen that
would you think of that whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]